here in this video we shall showcase to
you
the rows of all the incarnations of kong
and
also other apes from movies such as
george from rampage
mighty joe from mighty joe young aquid
from the legend of thousand and others
as well
we also have done quite a number of
these videos these monster rose videos
but not recently of apes and these giant
primers do give out an impressive sound
comb was the first giant monster of
movie screens and as such deserve a
video like this as well
so we will show you 15 of the best king
kong and
8 rows in the next few minutes so do
subscribe to be a part of the mind cue
family and now let's get roaring
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
let's see
[Music]
[Music]
look
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
boom
do
[Music]
uh
uh
george george george
[Music]
yes
uh
[Music]
[Music]
and so with this we come to the end of
the video of the 15 best common giant
aprils from
movies if you have a better list then
put them down in the comments section
we will send you a love anyway hit that
like button for support
subscribe to be a part of our family and
also smash that bell button for regular
updates on new master videos
right here on this channel till next one
take care fam